hey guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's edition of
what I eat in a day youtuber reviews I'm
gonna be taking a look at a healthy Emmy
now this one has been highly requested
for months on end and after taking a wee
peek at Emmys Instagram and YouTube I
knew I better get on it stat now Emmy is
a youtuber and vegan nutritionist who
advocates for a high carb plant-based
diet she is also the creator of the slim
on starch program which is an 8 week
weight loss program that allegedly helps
clients gain food freedom and lose
weight while on a high carb plant-based
diet without ever counting calories or
restricting portion sizes seems like a
bit of a dichotomy and interesting
selection of words but will get way more
into that soon now Emmy doesn't really
do traditional what a today videos that
I would normally review on my channel
but she does have several vegan weight
loss recipes and suggested full day meal
plans which is what we're gonna be
taking a closer look at today later on
we're gonna be looking at amis general
overview on her diet as well as some of
the health claims behind eating a high
carb plant-based vegan diet so
definitely stay tuned for that now
Before we jump into my review I want to
start with my in general disclaimer that
the information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always seek out the
help of a registered dietitian or
medical professional for your unique
case also this video in particular may
be a bit triggering for some people who
are currently or who have previously
struggled with disordered eating or an
eating disorder so feel free to skip
this video if you're unsure now without
further ado let's meet at me now I am
going to be showing you meals but here
is something that you have to know about
this meal plan there are no portion
sizes there is no calorie counting there
is no restriction if you have a plate of
what I show you and you're still hungry
have another one so shout out to all the
haters and goodbye to all the haters
that says
no calories have as much as you want
honeys eat as much as you want
fuel up and eat this food and feel good
and satiated and full set you can just
move on with your life
lose the weight and feel incredible
alright so that was a short and sweet
little intro to Emmy where she
introduces herself and welcomes all of
us honeys into her eat as much as you
want plant-based lifestyle program now
she also encourages her viewers to eat
to feel fueled and satisfied even if
that means having an extra portion of
food now I like the no calorie counting
thing but I am still skeptical about
what this actual meal plan involves so
of course I took a closer look now Emmys
slim on starch website has tons and tons
of positive testimonials of people who
have lost anywhere between a few pounds
to up to 70 pounds while the
testimonials do sound convincing in
terms of the amount of weight that
clients have been able to lose i doin a
flag that this is only an eight week
program so we really don't know anything
about the sustainability of this program
in the long run or if and how clients
have been able to maintain the weight
loss and judging by the fact that the
vast majority of people who go on
restrictive diets for weight loss end up
gaining the weight back also known as
weight cycling I'm definitely a
skeptical of this anecdotal evidence but
let's take a look at the recipes and
meal plans to see how they fit within
this food freedom philosophy that she
preaches lets her with breakfast
[Music]
Tomica pie oatmeal you know whatever it
is that you want to call it it is
delicious okay
so Amy's first breakfast is this carrot
cake or a pumpkin pie oatmeal and as you
probably know by now I am all for a
healthy bowl of oats in the morning and
this one has ODEs apple carrots pumpkin
and pumpkin pie spice super young and I
love the complex carbs and fiber from
the oats and the pumpkin and the carrots
and the apple but for a breakfast this
is pretty low in fat protein and also
calories it's just over like 200 per
bowl but by adding in some hemp parts or
nuts or even some nut butter it would
have made this a much more complete
breakfast meal to start the day again I
get that she said you can have a second
portion if you're hungry but it really
wouldn't fix the fact that this is just
straight-up carbs let's take a look at
day two 38 cents and that is 300
calories and then with that I had a
banana which came out to be 24 cents at
105 calories okay so we have another
oats recipe here and in this clip she's
talking about buying oats in bulk to
save money which is an awesome tip but
budgeting aside this meal is also very
carb heavy especially since one cup of
dry oats would yield about two cups
cooked now I can't speak for everyone
but I would have a really hard time
dragging myself through that volume of
oats if there wasn't some nuts or seeds
or maple syrup or cinnamon to help me
through even like a little pinch of salt
would really help bring out the flavor
and that is imperative in my books when
it comes to making oats anyway
flavor aside we are also getting about
82 grams of carbohydrate from
this one meal which translates to 41% of
the daily carbohydrate recommendations
for women and about 30% for men yes this
bowl has more protein than the last one
we just saw about 11 grams but that's
still not a lot considering there's 450
calories in it let's take a look at
breakfast number three oh boy okay um so
I'm glad to see we're getting a boost of
flavor with some cocoa powder and
cinnamon even though the amount of cocoa
and cinnamon is kind of like making my
mouth dry just to think about it so yeah
but again this recipe is just
straight-up carbs I mean it's low in
protein fat and calories it's just like
over 200 calories and less than four
grams of protein she could have
definitely made this more complete with
some nut butter on top or used myhacc
and pureed in some soft tofu so if you
didn't see that then definitely check it
out right here
but it's now obvious to me and also not
surprising when we remember the name of
the program is slim on starch that Emmy
is part of the high carb low fat
plant-based movement I'll go more into
detail on that in a bit but let's just
discuss the effects of having a strictly
high carb breakfast now there is some
research to suggest that enjoying a
high-fiber carbohydrate rich breakfast
may assist with weight management
efforts by maintaining satiety that
makes a lot of sense because fiber is
slow digesting and is really inherently
satiating having said that one 2016
study found that strictly high carb
breakfasts were associated with lower
metabolic rates and increased hunger
compared to higher protein breakfasts
this increased hunger was likely
associated and attributed to the kind of
up-and-down in blood glucose levels
after a really high carb breakfast
so while the fiber from the oats and the
sweet potato Bowl can definitely
contribute to satiety without a source
of adequate protein or fat to really
help mediate those blood sugar levels
you'll likely feel pretty hungry after
eating these breakfasts in general with
the exception of day two are also
generally pretty low calorie there's
really no protein and no fat so you're
going to definitely need to go for round
two and thank goodness amis plan says
it's okay for us to have a second or
third portion if you're hungry but man I
don't think I could do another whole big
bowl of oats or sweet potatoes even if I
was really hungry even with multiple
servings you might feel physically
satiated but not emotionally satisfied
at all and that is really really
important
Emme also mentions in her video that
bananas are best adjusted when they're
ripe so I want to talk a little bit more
about that right now so a bananas
ripeness will ultimately impact the rate
at which it affects blood sugar levels
so for instance bananas that are less
ripe have more resistant starch and as a
result have a lower glycemic index
meaning they don't create as much of an
increase in blood sugar levels and can
help keep you fuller longer the
resistance starch in less ripe bananas
or green bananas also functions like
soluble fiber by helping to relieve
constipation and feeding the good
bacteria in your gut as a banana ripens
the resistant starch starts to decrease
and is converted into sugars so while
ripe bananas may have less soluble fiber
so that they move through the system
faster there are actually a lot of
digestive benefits to eating unripe
bananas if you can personally I don't
like green bananas so I look at my
resistance starch sources elsewhere but
I just wanted to clear up that myth that
they're inherently bad for digestion
when arguably the opposite may be true
let's see what Emmy has in store for
lunch
[Music]
okay so I'm glad we're getting some more
substantial protein in this meal from
the huge amount of nutritional yeast
which provides about 31 grams of protein
for this meal and combined with these
small amounts of protein in the
mushrooms and potato this meal provides
a solid 46 grams of protein in totals
so I can't say I'm mad about that after
what we just saw at breakfast this meal
also provides about 440 calories and a
little more fat than breakfast so
basically like six grams still lots of
room to boost that up but not
surprisingly she doesn't cook with oil
which I talked about in this video here
and there's also no overt sources of
whole food fats either which really
isn't ideal but let's take a look at the
rest of Emmys recipes before making any
other conclusions one cup of dry rice
and then I got a can of beans a can of
beans is 79 cents all right and then in
the frozen section I got a pound of
broccoli lunch we've racked up 876
calories for only two dollars and 28
cents okay so this is Emmys
budget-friendly day kind of a boring
meal yes especially because there is no
seasoning on any of it but the
combination of rice beans and broccoli
can definitely provide a really balanced
and nutrient-dense meal having said that
I am a bit concerned about the portion
sizes and the fact that the ratios in my
books are totally off I can see guys why
you wanted me to comment on Emmy so much
okay so here we have one cup of dry rice
which yields about 3 cups of cooked rice
we've got a whole can of beans and a few
pieces of broccoli which in total adds
up to about a thousand calories and 200
grams of carbs for one meal
aka 67% of your total carb
recommendation for the day I mean this
could easily have been split up into two
or three meals ideally I would have
liked a seed like twice as much broccoli
definitely less rice and beans and a
little fat in there to help carry those
fat soluble vitamins this lunch meal
also lacks a lot of the satisfaction
factor with really no seasoning and
again no fat and even though we're
seeing some more protein in the lunch
compared to the breakfast recipes I kind
of feel like we went from zero to a
hundred with an entire can of beans
which again could have easily been split
up between several portions to last a
few days or a few meals we're also
getting about eighty eight percent of
your total fiber needs in this one meal
alone and I have a feeling we're gonna
blast totally pass those recommendations
as well but let's take a look at what
day three lunch is all about you have to
make sure that your meals have a good
source of starch so that's why to my
salad we are adding potatoes and beans
to make sure that not only do we get the
volume in there but we get this satiety
too we have to make sure that our diet
is centered around starch
okay well that's an interesting salad
dressing but I will say that this salad
is maybe the most balanced meal we've
seen so far even though it's still far
from ideal we're getting about 16 grams
of protein 16 grams of fiber and it
looks like a more adequate portion size
however the lack of fat at this point is
just kind of making me sad it is totally
your call if you prefer an oil-free
salad dressing like we've seen a lot of
youtubers for example make tahini
dressings without any oil which is still
great in my books because the tahini can
provide the body that we need but this
is not a dressing this is like a
fat-free hummus dip that looks kind of
like baby food I'm also just really
concerned with the lack of any nuts or
seeds or avocado or Omega threes which
is virtually non-existent in this diet
thus far but let's take a look at what
is in store for dinners
[Music]
okay so not only are we seeing a lot of
oil-free recipes but I'm also getting
the sense that Emmy doesn't add any salt
to her meals as we're seeing a real lack
of flavor going on I do not know what
poor soul is actually gonna follow any
of these recipes to a tee
but anyways as for the nutrition of this
recipe even though there's no complete
source of protein we are getting about
17 grams of trace amounts of protein
from each ingredient like the squash
rice spinach and artichoke arts I
actually think this would be a pretty
tasty combination but I would be a
little more protein maybe from some
beans or tofu or some fat from like
tahini or nuts and definitely some salt
and pepper to make this edible we are
also seeing a ton of fiber for one meal
about 80 percent of your total daily
needs in this meal alone so it's gonna
be interesting to see how this whole day
pans out let's take a look at day two
and then about seventy seven calories
for the broccoli so that comes out to
seven hundred and seventy seven yeah I
don't really know where to start here
I'm not even sure how you do a beauty
hero shot of a plate like that I
personally would have a hard time with
that creatively speaking but anyways
this meal is pretty consistent with what
we've seen from Amy's recipes so far no
fat no seasoning very carb heavy it's a
substantially larger portion than what
would be considered normal for one meal
this meal is also again very high in
fiber at 30 grams which is enough to
meet an individual's fiber needs for an
entire day but one thing I do want to
highlight about this meal is the protein
content so far we've seen that Amy's
recipes are either very low in protein
or the protein content comes from large
quantities
beans oats or nutritional yeast in this
case despite not having a traditional or
complete protein source this recipe
actually provides 30 grams of protein
which is considered an appropriate
amount of protein for one meal and while
broccoli and potatoes naturally contain
some amount of protein you would need to
eat very large quantities of these foods
in order to meet your protein needs most
people would have a really hard time
with that myself included so to give you
an example of how I would change this up
you could easily reduce the amount of
potatoes down to about a cup add about
three quarters to a cup of tofu that's
maybe cooked and a little bit of olive
oil or at least topped with some sesame
seeds cashew nuts or a little peanut or
tahini dressing and we want to keep the
veg in there but one or two cups of
broccoli would be great that would have
about half the calories as emmys but
would deliver so much more on the
satiety and satisfaction factor plus we
would get a more balanced nutrient
profile just a suggestion let's finish
off with day three
[Music]
all right so same same but different
right and I gotta say the music in those
hero shots is really really hilarious
but anyways lots of complex carbs from
the brown rice sweet potato and corn on
the cob some veggies in there way too
much fiber from one meal and not much
else
let's break things down overall there
are definitely some common themes in
amis meals with the high amounts of
fiber low amounts of fat inconsistent
amounts of protein and portion sizes and
of course large volumes of starch basic
carbs looking at our nutrient analysis
the amount of fat in amis recipes makes
up about five to eight percent of the
total calories which is far below the 20
to 35 percent recommended macronutrient
range for fat we also know that this
diet is very high carb and provides
seventy to eighty two percent of total
calories from carbohydrates which is
well above the recommended 45 to 65
percent range the overall protein range
was low to moderate but not overly
concerning as we did see some protein
from a few different sources but to meet
those needs you would often have to
consume unrealistic portion sizes that
are highly unlikely for most people to
attain I don't know about you but I
cannot eat three cups of unseasoned rice
or two cups of unflavored oats also
given the fact that this is a high carb
diet it's no surprise that the fiber
content of these recipes is above the
recommended 25 to 30 grams per day
recommendation and instead provides up
to 65 grams of fiber per day now while
I'm all about meeting our fiber targets
as many people do not even meet these
targets eating a large amount of fiber
especially for those who are new to
plant-based can cause severe bloating
pain gas diarrhea constipation and even
reduce the absorption of some nutrients
so I mean
I guess what I'm saying is get to know
your toilet now in terms of calories
they're pretty much all over the map and
although Emmy does encourage eating
until you feel satisfied and not
limiting portion sizes or counting
calories the total calories from these
recipes are either way below or
surpassed the recommended range for
somebody like Emmy so it's ranging from
1200 calories to 2,400 calories which
would be pretty confusing for a lot of
people also just based on what we've
seen from Emmys oil-free vegan recipes
they're all pretty restrictive in fat
seasoning and sometimes also protein and
calories so I would worry that you're
either going to feel super unsatiated
physically and this level of restriction
may trigger a bit of a binge or you may
be so freakin bored with this diet and
like a variety that you have no appetite
at all so you just don't meet your
nutrient needs at all and I mean is
misery really the best way to lose
weight I think not anyway I also want to
talk a little bit about the health
impacts of a really high carb low fat
diet although there is definitely strong
research to support a predominantly
plant-based diet I do caution towards
consuming a very high carb low fat diet
as evidence on this is a bit
controversial most studies have found
that neither very low carb or very high
carb diets are optimal and both can
contribute to increased mortality rate
however studies have found a bit of a
sweet spot of about 50 to 55 percent of
total calories from carbohydrates being
associated with lower risk of mortality
on the other hand a high carbohydrate
diet of more than 70% has been
associated with increased mortality and
if you can recall Emmys meal plans
provide about seventy to eighty two
percent of calories from carbohydrates
there's also been conflicting research
showing that high carb diets have been
associated with both the development and
prevention of type 2 diabetes and
cardiovascular disease which is likely
explained by the differences in glycemic
index of the
this is why it's really important to
mention that not all carbs are created
equal
I will say that the carbohydrates that I
mean chooses are typically higher
quality and lower glycemic index but
with such little variety little flavor
and well I don't know joy I would worry
that it's gonna be damn hard for a lot
of people to maintain this without
slipping into some kind of high fat high
sugar high calorie binge there are also
a lot of risks associated with a really
low fat diet because it could increase
the risk of infertility as well as
nutrient deficiencies because fat is
necessary in the diet in order to absorb
fat soluble vitamins like vitamins d e K
and a in addition studies have shown
that low fat diets can put one at risk
for the development of depression which
may be partially due to a restriction
and omega-3 fats which we know is linked
with brain health I will definitely be
speaking more about some of these
concerns in a moment but first my usual
questions in general is this way of
eating balanced now before I answer this
question I want to take a look at what
Emme actually has to say about the
overall nutrition and health claims of
this diet let's go ahead and look and we
see here that we have indeed it reached
all of our targets and even surpassed
them I mean look at fiber that is just
bananas and every single vitamin that we
needed we got in mineral as well the
only thing is b12 which should be
supplemented on this diet either through
pills or shots or drops but other than
that I mean let's look at all of our
vitamins we hit everything except for
vitamin E the story behind this is that
we need vitamin E to protect ourselves
against a high-fat diet but we are not
eating a high-fat diet so we don't have
to hit that RDA so that is absolutely
fine and then if we look down at our
minerals we have hit everything except
for sodium the sodium actually was not
as high as it says in chronometer
because we did not add any salt we
didn't get
and beans with salt um so it was
actually quite lower but you could add
liquid aminos you could add iodized salt
or pink Himalayan salt if you are
worried about your sodium levels and the
the one that you might be wondering
about is how did we hit it is selenium
because you usually selenium is quite
hard to hit on a low-fat diet however
the brown rice and the oh it's really
helped us out there by getting a lot of
selenium so that is a great thing to
note as well and then my favourite of
all is protein we got nearly 80 grams of
protein on this day and knocked it out
of the park I mean we're over 200% on
every single one of these proteins so we
will not be protein deficient or
deficient in the bank either okay so
first of all I am glad that Emmy
mentions supplementing with vitamin b12
as this is very important for somebody
following a vegan diet high carb low
carb whatever but it looks like Emmy is
playing into the pervasive myth that
more is always better now while certain
nutrients like iron are tightly
regulated by the body meaning that the
body will adjust the rate of absorption
when it's getting too much from food an
excessive amount of some other nutrients
however can potentially have negative
health implications for example we are
seeing really high phosphorus intakes
ranging anywhere between 4500 to 7800
milligrams and some studies have found
an association between high dietary
phosphorus with increased disease risks
with intakes of more than a thousand
milligrams a day
emi's recipes are providing up to seven
times that amount and excess of
phosphorus can of course cause things
like diarrhea as well as hardening of
the organs and soft tissues and higher
amounts of phosphorus can also affect
your body's ability to use other
minerals like iron calcium magnesium and
zinc I also really need to speak to the
bold vitamin e claims here so while
studies have shown that the antioxidant
properties of vitamin E supplementation
can have anti-inflammatory effects for
those on a high-fat diet that is not the
only reason
why
need vitamin e the antioxidant powers of
vitamin E also help repair damaged cells
as a result of normal environmental
exposures things like air pollution UV
light and cigarette smoke it also plays
a really important role in brain
function red blood cell formation muscle
repair immunity and eye health so to say
that you don't need it because you're
not eating a lot of fat is totally
absurd it's also fat soluble meaning
that you need fat in the diet to be able
to absorb this nutrient so while the
numbers may show she is just moderately
deficient in vitamin E when you also
factor in that she's also deficient in
fat I would be concerned that the actual
amount that her body is getting is even
lower so with all of this in
consideration do I think that this way
of eating is balanced no definitely not
a vegan diet can be balanced 100% but it
does not need to be done with these
massive portions of starch just to meet
basic nutrient requirements this high
carb vegan diet that we're seeing from
Emmie takes things up a notch by also
restricting fat and really narrowing
down the available food options to
really only a handful of foods so of
course you're gonna end up having to eat
a lot more on this diet to feel
physically satiated and you're at high
risk of binging or overeating due to
emotional and dissatisfaction and bottom
line a mountain of unseasoned broccoli
and potatoes just makes this dietitian
really sad now are there any problematic
claims or assumptions made by this
channel get comfortable folks because
there is a lot to unpack here so let's
see what she has to say about the diet I
don't believe in counting calories I
don't believe in restricting your
portions and so I eat unlimited amounts
of these foods do i stuff myself to the
brim and eat like it's Thanksgiving
every single day no because I eat to
feel energized
I don't take the fact that I can eat as
much as I want as a free card to gorge
myself on all these foods I use these
foods as fuel to fuel my body to feel
incredible okay so if Emmy feels like
she thrives eating this way then all the
power to her however I do in a flag that
even though her food philosophy is all
about eating in abundance and not
restricting calories or portion sizes
restriction is not just about quantity
but also about quality and variety this
is the difference between the experience
of anorexia and orthorexia for example
the fact that we're cutting out meat
dairy vegan meat substitute any
processed foods sugar fat and salt
really narrows things down to a handful
of safe foods and that level of
restriction can be really triggering for
a lot of people now let's get into the
Nitty Gritty of some of her claims so
let's talk about the question where do I
get my protein well all foods have
protein and so long as you are eating
enough calories you're getting an
adequate amount of protein so I really
hate the assumption that getting enough
protein in a diet is strictly calorie
dependent because it still is very
possible to eat enough calories or even
surpass your daily caloric needs and
still not get the protein that we need
and we've seen this from other youtubers
that I've reviewed on the channel but
yes some fruits and vegetables may have
trace amounts of protein sometimes like
1% protein or less but the likelihood
that people are able to consistently
meet their protein needs without any
sufficient sources is highly unlikely
for vegans specifically studies have
shown that vegan diets do tend to be
lower in protein when they're not
executed appropriately in addition to
also potentially being low in other
nutrients like calcium zinc vitamin b12
vitamin D and iron again this is when
they're not well-planned
but this is often
vegan diets are high in fiber which is a
good thing but it can also make you feel
really full so it may actually be more
difficult sometimes to eat enough
calories to meet those protein needs if
you're just relying on things like
broccoli and potatoes for protein I also
don't like the mixed messaging where she
insists that you get enough calories in
order to meet your nutrient needs while
simultaneously discouraging calorie
counting folks we cannot eat this
unbalanced intuitively and not worry
about meeting our needs let's take a
look what she has to say about that
where are the healthy fats because there
seems to be an obsession with healthy
fats but just like I said about protein
and so long as you are getting an
adequate amount of calories you're
getting an adequate amount of fat
because all foods have fat sweet
potatoes have fat oh let's have a really
good amount of fat 15 to 20 percent fat
brown rice has a lot of fat all of these
foods have fat in them and as long as
you're getting enough calories you're
gonna get enough fat and developing a
fat deficiency is very very difficult if
we look at even the Okinawans the
Okinawan ate a very low-fat diet about 5
to 7 percent fat and they were part of
the Blue Zones the areas of the world
where individuals lived to be 100 years
old and they were thriving on a diet of
sweet potatoes so to seek out foods that
are higher in fat like nuts seeds and
avocado and supplement them for the
purpose of getting healthy fats do what
if you want to but it's not absolutely
necessary and I even reached out to dr.
Anthony Lim and I asked him is it
necessary for women to consume nuts
seeds and avocado for hormonal reasons
he said there is no evidence to prove
this and he referenced the Okinawan
women who were wonderfully healthy and
wonderfully fertile now I will say that
some individuals do find that they have
to include these overtly fatty foods
like nuts seeds and avocados in order to
keep a period because they're not
getting enough calories if they don't
consume those foods there's also some
talk about needing healthy fats for
brain functioning but fats actually
don't cross the brain barrier so that's
not the case okay so lots of things to
clear up here
um out of all the foods that she
mentioned having fat oats have the most
fat but you would need to consume six
and a half cups of oats to hit the
recommended 20 percent of your calories
from fat everything else is very low in
fat and just like what we said about
protein the idea that fat is calorie
dependent is wildly misleading as we saw
from the nutrient analysis I did
regardless of the amount of calories
that amis recipes provide the overall
fat content was still less than 10
percent probably because she didn't eat
seven cups of oats I mean who could but
to say that it's not necessary to eat
anything like avocado or not sir seeds
for fat on a vegan diet and to only rely
on calories is honestly really
irresponsible coming from a nutrition
professional now in this rant Emmy also
references the Okinawa diet which is the
unique diet that's been credited to
lengthening the lifespans of citizens of
Okinawa Japan now the traditional
Okinawa diet though not an exclusive
vegan diet is pretty low in calories and
fat and is very high in carbohydrates
largely as a result of the available
foods that was in the region now the
longevity of the Okinawan people is
largely attributed to the high
antioxidant content and
anti-inflammatory properties of the
vegetables in this diet not the fact
that it is low in fat especially because
we see other regions of Japan who eat a
lot of fatty fish and who are also
seeing reductions in chronic disease as
for the comment about getting a period
yes eating enough calories is absolutely
the most important dietary piece to
healthy ovulation and menstruation but
that may still play an important role
one study actually did find that getting
adequate DHA which is a type of omega-3
was also associated with a lower risk of
an ovulation as for the discussion on
dietary fats and brain health the
positive effects of omega-3s on brain
health is well documented in the
literature
studies have shown that the EPA and DHA
in omega-3 fatty acids are vital for the
maintenance of normal brain function and
are abundant in the cell membranes of
the brain in fact some studies have
shown that lower levels of DHA in the
blood have been associated with smaller
brain size which is a sign of
accelerated brain aging furthermore
research has shown that omega-3 fats may
help protect against neuro degeneration
and the development of cognitive
impairment can help prevent and treat
anxiety and depression and can even
improve mental disorders like bipolar
disorder and schizophrenia on the flip
side not getting enough omega-3s is
linked with learning impairment so with
that in consideration it sounds to me
that dietary fats like omega-3s
do a pretty good job at crossing the
blood-brain barrier in fact omega-3s
have not only been shown to cross the
blood-brain barrier but some studies
suggests that it may actually help
preserve its integrity next now let's
take a look at what she has to say about
calcium
the harsh reality is that when we
consume animal protein this is something
like milk has animal protein in it our
bones have to release something alkaline
because of the acidity of the dairy so
something acidic comes into our
bloodstream and our bones have to
release something to balance out the pH
and unfortunately our bones release
calcium so if you look at you know
correlations around the world and I'm
not saying this is causation but the
correlation it's like come on between
dairy consumption and bone fractures and
osteoporosis in different countries the
more dairy that is consumed the more
osteoporosis and bone fractures there
are in the country so my calcium levels
according to my blood test were perfect
as well so we're good to go doing what
we're doing okay so first of all I would
love to know what's this something that
Emmy is referring to that's apparently
released from our bones when we drink
dairy but anyways regardless of what
that something is I will just say right
off the top that there is nothing that
you can eat
will alter your blood pH the pH of our
blood is actually very tightly regulated
so whether you eat something acidic or
alkaline our blood pH will not be
effective so this is not something that
really any of us have to be that
concerned with assuming that we're
healthy now as for the evidence on Dairy
Milk and bones there is so much to
unpack here I'm just gonna actually
leave some links below to some blog post
that I did about this specifically but
the correlational research that she's
referring to suggesting that there were
higher hip fractures in developing Asian
countries with higher milk intakes was
actually debunked by the fact that
physical activity was not considered and
when physical activity was put into the
equation the discrepancy actually
disappeared as for the pH claim when
examining a number of randomized control
studies on the effects of types of
protein animal and plant-based increased
intakes a protein not only didn't
increase adversities in bone calcium but
rather protein was shown to be actually
beneficial to bone mineral density as
for the concern of acidic phosphates in
milk causing calcium excretion Xin urine
other animes control studies have shown
no changes in urine calcium balance now
ultimately I say you can get calcium and
vitamin D from lots of sources not just
milk not just dairy and I don't care how
you get it I am NOT a milk pusher I mean
I don't even drink glasses of cow's milk
myself but but to claim that dairy
explicitly is leaching calcium from your
bones is just not well supported by the
research next those those pastries cakes
and cookies it's not the sugar in there
that's causing weight gain it's the fat
in there and of course it is essential
that you have excess calories in order
to gain fat so if you're eating less
calories and you're burning you could
eat a bunch of Twinkies and you're not
going to gain weight but if you're
eating more calories than you're burning
then it's the fat that's being stored as
fat so all the sugar and that stuff is
not being converted into fat it's the
fat that's being converted into fat
because those products are so high
in calories okay Wow well let's just
make one thing clear carbohydrates have
calories that also has calories protein
has calories oh and so do all basically
foods other than I guess water so if you
were to theoretically have zero fat in
your diet and you were to overeat
lollipops or fat-free muffins you will
store those carbohydrates as fat now
this brings me to my main beef with Emmy
which is her co-opting of the term food
freedom Andy's idea of food freedom is
that because a high carb low fat diet is
naturally lower in calories you can
therefore eat more food and she even
says you can pile your plate high this
whole volume eating strategy is a common
diet tactic to really fill yourself up
on high water high-fiber foods with very
little substance so that you don't gain
weight when you're heavily restricting
foods you enjoy there's often a
psychological need to eat a lot of
volume as you kind of are searching for
a little bit more satisfaction but if we
were just to add a little protein and
maybe some fat with our meals we could
boost that's a tiny factor without the
need for massive portions and when we
add a little bit of salt in there or I
don't know heaven forbid sugar for
flavor
we add even more satisfaction when these
two things are not aligned it's a pretty
good indicator of an unsustainable
unhealthy diet ultimately this is a diet
packaged up with a pretty new shiny Bo
and repackaged as a healthy lifestyle in
fact all of the diet messages I'm seeing
in this program are completely at odds
with the concept of food freedom or
intuitive eating it is not enough to say
hey eat as much as you want when you can
only eat a handful of different foods
all of which are basically coming from
one single food category starch
restriction whether through quantity or
types of food is inherently
at odds with intuitive eating and food
freedom unfortunately I am just
scratching the surface on the
misinformation on this channel but I am
pregnant I am tired and now I am pretty
hungry for some like peanut butter so I
just need to put this all to bed bottom
line I have always said that the best
diet is the one that you can sustain
over time all your life and while this
diet may seem to work for Emmy I am very
concerned about the risk for physical
health in the form of severe nutritional
deficiencies and emotional health in the
form of disordered eating and orthorexia
and on that note I think that is really
all we need to say about it right I mean
this one was a doozy so if you like this
video definitely please be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]